in terms of the background will Sam
Kiely alluded to it earlier on this
shouldn't sadly come as any surprise to
Australians the terror threat in
Australia was raised quite some months
ago too severe as a result of threats
from the Islamic state although we
should stress that at this stage
although he p that you can see him on
the right there wearing that black
bandanna there is no direct confirmed
link to Islamic state or is as there as
they are known but there is a history
there is a link between Islamic state
and Australia we saw back in July to
Australian citizens fighting for is in
Syria was seen carrying the severed
heads of two Syrian soldiers that was I
guess the moment at which Australia like
many other countries around the world
woke up and realized that this was their
problem as it was a Middle Eastern
problem and then this video emerged we
can have a little listening to this
video now these soldiers we will not
stop fighting on top of Buckingham
Palace until we put the black flag on
top of the White House we will not stop
and we will keep on fighting and we will
fight you and we this gentleman is a an
Australian citizen he was confirmed to
be an Australian citizen he is still
thought to be in Syria where that video
was filmed and he's been well the
Australians made it quite clear if he
comes back he will be immediately
arrested and that led to Australia
committing several hundred soldiers as
Britain in other countries have done to
Iraq to northern Iraq to help the
Kurdish fighters fight is so clearly
Australia is very much part of this we
saw in September terror arrests taking
place unprecedented terrorist across
several cities in Australia some 800
armed officers 15 arrests 25 arrest
warrant so that's the backdrop and you
can see here the latest arrest was just
yesterday at an individual 25 years old
was arrested on terror related charges
so that's the backdrop and tragically
for Australians they are now waking up
to the reality that there is terror on
the streets of sydney